well bill this is such a stunning report
we're going to keep dr. Glassman of
jpmorgan on with us for a few minutes
well bill this is something you have
spoken about in your notes for years in
that within all of consensus there can
always be a shock is this a report
enough of a shock to alter fed action I
think it's enough of a shock tanta to
delay June into July for sure you know
the fittest tried to convince us that
one or two hikes this year as in the
cards and I think they want and
renormalize the yield curve and
renormalized short-term rates but a
number like this certainly cancels out
to my way i think in june in combination
with brexit so we'll wait for another
one and look for july but remember so
low that they've got to take well a
number like this but which number are
you looking at the Fed cares much less
about the non-farm number of month to
month and they do about the unemployment
rate yeah they do an N word
four-point-seven percent the
participation rate went down a few ticks
and maybe that's part of it we have the
verizon distortion you've mentioned that
a number of times so it's it's a
confusing report I would agree with with
you and Jim Glassman that basically it's
a normal report without the number in
terms of payroll so will will simply
have to see going for